hey everyone it's Mike from autoflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for this video or
I'll be talking about you know the
importance of heavy volume coming into
the market and you know this to me is is
an important topic that you know a lot
of Traders need to understand because
you know oftentimes you see a big order
hitting the market and you know people
are going to react to that because you
know when it comes down to trading order
flow you're really looking at
[Music]
um
the volumes that's trading and you know
a lot of Traders like to focus in on the
big volume so before I jump into today's
topic
um you know I want you to make sure you
subscribe to the channel hit the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new uploads and you know I've been
getting some great comments from you
guys I've been getting emails from you
guys saying hey you know what we really
appreciate the videos keep them coming
um and you know be sure to leave some
comments on some videos that you'd like
to see in the future I'm sort of trying
to line up a day where I could go
through all the comments and make videos
specifically
um as uh I don't want to say rebuttal
but rather
um you know to answer your questions
that you have because you know order
flow is a very robust way of looking at
the market so
your support right your comments really
go a long way in helping me create you
know push me to create more uh videos
just like this one so let's go ahead and
get started on today's topic which is
about the big volume coming into the
market because in my opinion it's
something that is is often you know
overlooked by Traders okay and when
you're talking about order flow now you
know some people will say oh you know
the footprint is not order flow because
it's not tracking the orders as they're
coming in what order what the footprint
chart does is it tracks the orders as
they trade okay and
let me just uh get something up here all
right where's my Dome just bear with me
here
okay so you know the dome right people
say no the Dome this is the order flow
because you can see the orders going in
and out of the market well the problem
with that is yeah you know
problem is it's not trading you know
yeah it's nice to see that something
came in this is by ultrabons you know to
see there's 315 offered at 13 but as you
know right as the market starts to trade
up 9 10 11 the 315 orders get pulled
right so there's always
um games being played with that people
trying to game the system if you don't
believe me go to the cftc website
um you know you you see every year
they're catching people for spoofing the
markets right so and then other markets
I mean Ultra bonds is a pretty slow
Market but if you're looking at say mnq
or NQ right it's moving super fast right
and you just you know you see the bid
offer it's you know it's three ticks
right it's just jumping around it it's
just super fast right how you gonna make
heads or tails out of what's going on
when every volume is you know you know
15 contracts more or less you know
sometimes it's six sometimes it's 14.
um you know on a market like e-minis
okay it's very liquid in the sense that
yeah you've got hundreds at each level
you know people say oh you got 300 here
there's support coming in right but
really as a Trader what you want to
focus in on is where that heavy volume
is coming in and more importantly
trading okay because once it's trades
people are committed to a position
because they're going to want to get out
at some point
okay so you know that's the Dome that's
sort of the difference I'm not not
knocking the Dome I know I have some
friends that trade strictly off a dome
and they're very successful with it
you know they've been doing that for
many years that's their Niche just like
for me a footprint is the niche and I
like look at now you know other people
will use a a heat map okay let's say oh
look at this we've got this big bit in
here coming in at 46 and a half
obviously you got support I mean even
here at 48 and a half oh there's a big
bid I'm gonna start buying it right
they're going to look for this Market to
go up and but as you can see right here
there was nice offers here at uh 54 and
three quarter or 55 and then 55 and a
half but it traded through those okay
I've always been a big believer and this
is something I learned very early on
Market is attracted to size and it
didn't really click with me you know I
learned that
probably you know a year or two into
the business so to speak back in the 90s
is you know because why is Market
attracted to size is because once you
become a big Trader you need size to
trade against
okay so just sort of bear that in mind
and you can just see right here right
it's getting attracted to this bid here
at 48
and a half
okay and on the dome right you can see
earlier there was like 300 now it's back
down to 292. okay I wouldn't be
surprised to see this Market sort of
come down here and you know test it take
it out okay but now what I'm seeing you
know Market first reacted to the size
here at eight and a half and now it's
only the the
Dome Traders or the the heat map Traders
are they're reacting to it saying oh the
Market's already bouncing off of it so
now they're jumping in okay I mean
that's that's one way to look at the
market there's nothing wrong with that
right again I know people that trade
with a heat map and make a lot of money
I know people to trade with a dome and
they're very successful but I like to
look at the order flow because now I
know
Traders are committed to the market
right
based off of what I'm seeing in here
okay now and there you go it just broke
right through there
okay broke right through that level you
know everyone that was trying to buy it
here looking for this you know it came
down tested that level started bouncing
up
well now they got to get out they gotta
cover okay so you know the next level's
you know what was down here but they
don't really see much in the depth of
the book coming in here but anyway what
I want to talk about is stuff that
happened a bit earlier right there was
some nice big size that went through
um you can't even really tell here
on this heat map
what that size was okay now this is the
Ninja Trader one you know I I know
there's book map which is a great tool
um but this is the Ninja Trader uh heat
map that I'm looking at so
just going back here to earlier okay
all right so again you know cash opened
here 8 30 you start seeing the size
coming into the market now there was
1069 that came in here
I'm not too concerned about that because
it's coming in right at the busiest time
of the day but where it got really
interesting okay there was some decent
size that came in Market
made this low here at 34 and a half
rallied all the way up to 50 you know
guys high as 51. and then right in here
at 44
and what is that three quarters or 45
rather
there was a big bid that came in the
market 23.75 28.52
so that's you know about 5 000 contracts
okay and again you know people that are
watching the Dome
they see this big bid coming in now why
is this
important well we had just made a low
rallied up
15 points
pulling back then there's a bid a bid
coming in here okay is this going to
hold right is this going to be support
for this market and the Market's going
to go up or is it going to break and the
market is going to go back down you know
now some people you know they'll
other
um
bibs you know here oh I mean look at
that it's coming in really right at the
38 retracement area okay so all the PIP
guys are they're looking to get long
here
but if you're watching the order flow it
hits there it bounces up hits there
again gets through there it cleans out
that
bid at 45.
okay then it trades back up so everyone
that was buying here is like Yay you
know because Mark is going back up and
then slowly it starts coming back down
and this is where it gets important to
watch what's happening
on the footprint what's actually being
traded
so 23.75 28.52 then the next bar you
know 26 266 goes up it's above it it
starts coming back down is there still
going to be support in this market is
this big order sort of what's you know
what's the whole point of this order
because everyone's you know a lot of
Traders think that oh there's a big
order there's a big buyer this Market's
got to go up
okay well why are they buying we don't
know right we don't know because we're
not part of that trade we're not trading
it if you're looking at
let me just you know sort of pull this
in here let me just clean up this chart
really quick
um take off some of this stuff just get
a simple bar chart okay
you know from
yesterday what do we got here this is a
one minute chart remember right we've
been selling off this was
this is yesterday this is the day before
you know we're selling off from 4500 all
the way down you know to you know
where's Cash open somewhere in here
around 44.45 so you know over the last
several days you know almost you know 70
point sell-off I mean obviously
yesterday we had that big sell-off
um and today we're sort of continuing it
but
so who knows I mean this could have just
been someone taking profits from the day
before or two days before I don't know
what I do know
is this bid is done once it starts
coming down here it's only got to get
through 160 contracts here
and then it breaks down
okay once it stays below this level
of 44.45 once it closes below this level
and the staying clearly below this level
I could be looking for this Market to
potentially go test this low here
right now I'm not saying it's going to
sell off another 100 points or anything
but at least now I know that this buyer
he's done he's out of the way I don't
have to worry about him anymore
at 45.
Market comes back uh gets down to 38 so
it bounces back up to 42. so it comes
down in here tests the low here at 34
and three quarters again gets within two
ticks sort of comes back up to that 45
area you know was there some buying no I
mean there's 793 here but on the offer
side 500 900 471
you know to me this just sort of looks a
bit like normal order flow what was
again
not order flow but rather technical
analysis 101
if this was going to be support area
previous support becomes resistance
right right up here at 45 you know the
ICT guys will call this some special big
name but it's just really previous
support becomes resistance and then we
start going back down and then look we
get down here at this 44 40 area
okay just draw another line in here
two here
now
again we had traded down to 35 and a
quarter
back up to 45 and then sort of in the
midpoint
what do we see we see another big order
come in here right we see 1300
4 000. so another 5 000 contracts being
bought here at 40. first one was 45. now
another five points lower it's coming in
here at 40. again I don't know
if this is a new position maybe someone
you know saying oh this low is down here
at 34 and a half
um you know we did we did obviously
trade lower and then we're trading
around this area for
15 you know just from here at 9 21 to
here after this low has been made we're
trading around it for about 10 minutes
okay and then somebody stepped up said
yeah hey I'll buy 5 000 here okay let's
see if this is going to be support or
not well it hit there did it really
bounce you know if you're watching the
Dome you see this big massive bid
sitting in the Market at 40
you're jumping in front well if you
jumped in front
it only went up one two three ticks and
if you jumped in front at 40 and a
quarter it went up two ticks basically
one tick because only traded eight
contracts here before breaking down to
38 okay
then it's sort of rotating around it
here so you had a big bid coming in here
at 40.
well then we're trading below it then we
come back up
where's my bidder
198 367. he's not there
so if I know that the buyer that was
here at 40 is done
do I think the Market's going higher I
mean do I think there's any more support
coming in probably not then the market
breaks down right makes that new low at
34 and a quarter
but then it starts going up
all right
up up green candle green candle green
candle then it gets back up here to 45
now
see a big buyer coming in here 2307
at
at 44.45
. why is this one more important
think about it for a second here the
bids came in we were trading right
around that level for previous 10
minutes
here the bid came in again we were
trading around this level for about the
previous 10 minutes now we came down
made a new low and we're rallying we
rally about 10 points off the low
and now a big bidder comes in is this
the same guy that was buying earlier
over here
I don't know I don't know right but what
I do like about this is it's not coming
in in an area where it had been Trading
right in here to the left of the chart
right so it sort of gives me a little
bit of a sense that hey you know what
maybe someone's coming in and thinking
that this low the low of the day has
been made I'm more inclined to think
that the
the buyers here at 40 and earlier at 45
maybe they are fresh buys I mean I don't
know maybe people took a look at the
chart
you know after the chart had you know
after the market had sold off you know
70 points in the last couple of days and
thought it was a good buy but this one
here to me out of the three areas where
there's a heavy volume that came in
right here at uh at 8 40
you know 848 then here at uh
9 23 then here at 9 40. this is the
strongest one that I would be interested
in buying because the Market's already
moving up
off that low and it's coming in sort of
as to me as fresh buying that's how I
would identify this as opposed to this
one where we've sort of been trading
around
I mean is this one powerful I don't know
you know I mean I I don't like it in the
sense of even though it's a big volume
would I be looking to take that trade no
I mean it's an area where we're sort of
trading sideways because remember if
we're trading sideways
all right and how do I know we're
training side was well I just look to
the left
right sort of in the middle of this
range
that's an easy place to get off volume
to get off size
if you're a big Trader because you're
smack dab in the middle of the range
that's where you can move size without
impacting the market whereas this one
the market is rallying it's just rallied
10 points
and it's almost like someone's coming in
and say oh I got to get in I got
you know I want I think this Market I
think the low has been made and they're
buying it here at 45.
so I think this is more of a fresh Buy
whereas you know this one these two
earlier ones at 40 and at 45 earlier
were probably
in my opinion again I'm just postulating
it I don't know for sure because I'm not
involved in that trade
that it may have just been some short
covering from earlier
you know maybe the European session or
even the day before the day before that
whereas this one is more
to me it looks more like someone that's
aggressively looking to get long
to me there's more aggressive action in
this one than these previous ones okay
so
again you know if you're looking at the
dome right now we're back up above 50
here
it's hard to see the size because you
don't see you know no one's going to
plop in 2 000 contracts on the bid I
mean sometimes they do that to get a
specific reaction to the market but in
generally generally speaking
um you don't you know on the heat map
here
all right
you don't necessarily see it in there
okay now the
book map I believe you know they got
their ways of seeing it you know with
the bubbles and all that stuff but um
you know maybe you could have picked it
up there but I like it when I see big
size coming in on the bid in a move to
me that's more important than big size
coming in on the bid in a sideways
Market an area that you've just been
trading at for the last 10 minutes
all right because to me that that's more
of a sign of you know when a market is
going sideways when you see that big bid
coming in
it's just somebody is trying to get into
a position without necessarily moving
the market or get out of a position
without moving the market
but then once the market starts moving
and I see some guy sort of chasing it
plop in a big bit here a big bit of you
and up here at 47. I mean that that
matters more right so again it it's a
little bit more of a nuanced and
advanced concept for understanding what
you're seeing in the order flow but
when you see the big size
try to put it in context why is there a
big size coming in here what does that
mean is someone chasing a market that's
moving up thinking hey you know what
this is a great you know it's cheap here
I should buy it or an area where you
know maybe someone's is covering it from
the day before now again this one here
at 45 could be covering I don't know but
I just find this one much more appealing
at 45 then trying to buy it here at 45
okay
and again you know oh it's a 38
retracement okay but we know right
sometimes they hold sometimes they don't
hold so anyway guys I hope you guys
um are able to grasp this video and sort
of the importance of understanding where
um the heavy volume is coming and what
it means to the market
so
if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe to the channel so thanks again
for watching and being a part of my uh
you know my order flow trading Community
your support is appreciated and I'll see
you guys on the next video bye-bye
foreign